for you uh where do you see no jumper
going into into the new year because you
know obviously you're you are you're
doing a lot man and I can only assume
that like you're seem like the type of
person who kind of is cognitively aware
of when you not inspired or not into
something because you've said that over
the last year so like there's just times
where I'm just like what am I doing this
for right now I'm just having a good
time doing the interview which is really
why I started no jumber in the first
place is just CU I wanted you weren't
doing a lot of interviews it slowed down
for a little bit but for a while it
became like the focus of no jumper was
oh it's a bunch of friends aens friends
hanging out talking and it's like all
right there's basically like two
directions two primary directions that I
could go with no jumber I could do
interviews and focus on the platform
being about interviews and getting more
interviews and building up interviewers
or I could really kind of double down on
the whole homies hanging out talking
about [__] I'm G be real with you like
from a financial perspective the homies
hanging out talking to each other thing
is just not really the move because you
got to pay the dudes a pretty good
amount as you saw with the thing when
people left they left it feels like
they're going through that too well they
were complaining oh yeah they're
probably going through it too yeah but
like they're complaining about how much
they're getting paid and meanwhile I was
taking L on the content you know because
it just doesn't earn as much especially
live streams yeah like if we're just
going to come out here and hang out for
fun yeah like I I I got to make some
money I got kids yeah and when I think
about what I'm doing with my life it's
like if I live streamed all of my
interviews I would have probably missed
out on like I don't know like a million
dollars this year or like many hundreds
of thousands of dollars because chopping
them into clips and putting them out
like that is just so much more
beneficial to us than putting them
online and having it age restricted or
whatever and it's like for me at the end
of the day I I would like to do our
interviews live I mean it's kind of
scary because sometimes people want you
to take [__] down you got to cut [__]
out whatever but I got to think about
the business side of things remember
when Rogan was doing his [__] before he
went to Spotify all his [__] was live a
lot of people used to do it live and
kind of realized at a certain point that
it just wasn't really worth it well
you've kind of changed but he's also
someone who's not really trying to like
make money through streaming on YouTube
which we are like we have to kind of pay
for all our employees and everything by
doing that so for you uh you've I've
noticed you've reversed the way you were
dropping
interviews where you would do you're
doing clips now then the full thing yeah
that started because of people like thf
Bay and uh and uh fyb J main where I
would you know pay them for the
interview and then it's kind of like
okay well how are we going to make the
most money from this well I guess we
basically have to drop it in Clips
before we drop the full thing and then
we started just kind of doing that with
everything for a while and then I went
like one month I don't even know if the
fans noticed this but I went like one
month where I was primarily dropping
everything full interview first and then
Clips on the clips Channel and I feel
like the content kind of gets more
attention if you drop it clip by CLI and
I I see it how it is with Vlad and I
found that Vlad is usually right about
everything he's been doing that forever
he's just been doing it forever and he's
so analytical and he's so like capable
of looking at what is going to do what
but I mean some of the interviews I do
like are with such Fringe Niche
characters that it just doesn't really
feel right to drop it clip by clip so
I'm kind of like in a weird place where
I want to drop certain things the full
thing up front and then other things
clip by clip so I'm still kind of trying
to figure it out yeah I'm trying to
figure figure what I'm going to do with
this NBA young boy content I got cuz we
got so much and it's like we want to
make sure we take advantage of it you
know cuz it's a big situation definitely
and and knowing that the best moments
from your footage with him are going to
end up on Twitter getting millions of
views that you will not participate in
in any way aside from people saying like
oh I saw you in that young boy thing on
Twitter Twitter for sure that's what
happened every day I get hit with that
big Boogie clip where he's he's on my
[__] platform and he was talking he
said he got paid like offer $10 million
to go to college I see people always
saying like this was the biggest lie
ever told or some [__] it definitely
might have been so you're you're open to
paying people for interviews nowadays is
that something you because you didn't do
that always right I never really did it
before but over time it's kind of like
you know again we all have our platforms
and you got to look at it as a business
and it's like sometimes you know I'll
pay a couple thousand for an interview
and make 10,000 or 15,000 yeah like the
trade-off makes sense and you're going
to pay for the ones you know you're
going to get your money back on and I
think it's just only Fair because to a
certain extent like you know the the
people are not idiots like somebody like
fyj M like what reason would he have to
go do a bunch of podcasts aside from
getting paid from him if he knows that
no jumber is going to make $10,000 off
doing an interview with him he's going
to get in there and say I want three I
want 4,000 I want whatever and uh yeah
he hit me cuz I dm'd him I was like yo
you're funny come on the show sometime
and he's trying to get bag I just said
hey man it's not what I do over here
buddy but much love to you brother but I
understand I said keep hustling I ain't
mad at you though yeah same thing with
crit Mac crit Max's the only guy I
considered paying he want $500 but I was
like I I at the time he was doing so
many interviews yeah what are you going
to ask him to and so I was like I was
like yo what I was like maybe we go
skydiving or something like you know
what I mean like some random [__] you
know like that's very Mac Adventures
that was but then he started doing that
yeah so it was like ah they're they're
already kind of you know because that's
the whole thing with uh with with j m is
this that like he does content on his
own platform as well he does little
interviews with t Savage and [__] like
that and it's like well that content he
knows exactly how much that content make
so he could probably do the math and
figure out how much money I'm making off
of him so yeah like we just did a video
a vlog with u Mexican OT where we went
and murdered hogs in a helicopter and it
did great but like really like we didn't
make money off it it just kind of paid
for the trip paid for itself yeah which
is fine though because it was a dope
video and it brought a bunch of
subscribers and it kind of you know I
think it's like the second Vlog we've
done cuz you've been doing Vlogs forever
I haven't so that was the second one we
ever did yeah and so the first one was
did really well the second one did well
so I was like you know what this is we
don't have to make money on this yeah I
mean it's good to just do [__] in
general like if I go to you know I mean
really if I'm going to go do a vlog even
in like the LA area even if it's like a
day trip I mean it's going to have to
make kind of a significant amount of
money to cover like you know the the
filmmer which obviously my film are like
on salary and [__] like that but like
even just having security with you all
of a sudden then it's like oh okay this
content is costing quite a bit more
because you got to pay for all these
different things I don't necessarily
think that like us doing like Vlogs make
sense if you have a big idea that's
going to really like get the viewers in
but the viewers are allergic to like
lazy content at this point they just
know and it did not used to be like that
people used to just watch whatever
they'd watch whatever and now it's much
more Cutthroat and I've heard a lot of
like very big channels in this space
tell me that this year was a drop off in
Revenue that they never really
experienced before and I don't think I
can say that I definitely think that I
probably made as much in 2023 as I made
in 2022 which is counterintuitive to
some people because they're like oh you
got less views but I had 33 people on
staff uh at one point last year and now
they don't see the back end of the
business we almost cut our staff in half
and I mean that might sound kind of you
guys had 33 at one point yeah wow well
including like a lot of hosts and stuff
I actually I'm only saying that because
we're just doing Christmas bonuses and
it was like oh like we have way less
heads that we need to take into account
but I mean you got to think about the
business that way at a certain point
like am I paying people that aren't
producing a return for me are you uh
doing a christm party this year cuz last
year's is kind of lives in infamy was it
why I've seen like I saw a video where
it was like everybody who was there and
then they're gone yeah it it it was it
was whoever edited edit did a great job
cuz it made I don't think I ever
actually saw it I just saw like the
first two seconds in the Reddit and I
was like I'm not watching this I kept
scrolling but you guys are going to do a
no jumper holiday party this year yeah
it was do a little something yeah little
little shindy your birthday looked fun I
was on the list and then I wasn't on the
list really yeah you guys invited me you
hit me and I told you I was coming I got
a text the day of saying you're no
longer on the list what I swear to God
you could have definitely came I mean
the the I did hear like a couple other
people say that too I got a text it was
like uh thank you but you're no longer
on the list really after I got a text
that said you're confirmed on the list
so you would have came otherwise yeah
but I'm like hit me up dude it's your
there was a lot of people in there that
were not supposed to be there I
certainly was not tripping wow chilled
with my kids but I'm also not the person
that's going to bother you a few other
people told me that that happened where
like that because that CU I could have
bothered you or Josh but I was like you
know what I'm not going to [__] show
up and be the guy standing outside
trying to [__] get in like you could
have just texted me and I would have
fixed it for you right away cuz that
happened with a couple other people but
I didn't know how like a [__] good
shind dig though that was probably the
best party we ever did but you know
we're talking about spending a lot of
money on [__] I mean we spent like a 100
racks on that party and I mean well you
guys had sponsors though no we didn't
really get sponsors we just decided to
just do it like we didn't even bother
try to get alcohol sponsor because that
right there like the alcohol would have
been like minus 10 or 15 grand worth of
product on you know if we had had a
sponsor but I don't know and then like
the reality show that cost almost
$100,000 to put together the rental
paying the talent the the and the crew
insane and it's like are you going to be
able to make $100,000 off four YouTube
videos I mean they would have to get
like two million views each and the last
episode got age restricted so it like
really didn't earn as much y that age
restricted [__] sucks but we chose to do
that anyway just because I think it's
good to have like a template of look at
what we can put together look at the
scale of the production
yeah cuz maybe now you can sell um you
could be a production company for that
was kind of our idea was like let's make
the [__] KPM dating show and then he
got locked up like damn the crit Mac
dating show would have been heat a lot
of even the comments were suggesting
that idea even though we'd already been
talking about it because just such an
obvious layup I think damn yeah